y el movimiento las vidas negras
importan reviven brasil por tercer día
consecutivo cientos de personas se
manifestaran en distintas ciudades del
país para reclamar justicia por el caso
de joao alberto silveira un hombre negro
que murió luego de que fuera golpeado
por dos guardias de seguridad en un
supermercado de cadena en la ciudad de
puerto alegre
una situación que evoca la muerte del
estadounidense 'george floyd que desató
una ola de protestas alrededor del mundo
y estamos luchando no solo por joao
alberto que se fue sino por todas las
otras vidas que se perdieron y que
necesitan justicia hay que hacer
justicia
joao alberto habría tenido una discusión
con una cajera del establecimiento
comercial y por ello fue retirado por
los guardias de seguridad hasta la
puerta donde fue agredido ambos sujetos
fueron detenidos y responderán ante la
justicia por homicidio pero las
autoridades dijeron que no se trataba de
un acto de racismo
cuando vas al mercado te pueden asesinar
cuando estás dentro de tu casa también
te pueden asesinar por ser negro en
brasil cuando el vicepresidente de la
república dice que no hay racismo en
este país él no conoce brasil obras el
domingo los medios de comunicación de
brasil publicaron algunos detalles de la
vida de joao alberto entre ellos que
estuvo detenido por porte ilegal de
armas y violencia doméstica la
información fue aprovechada por grupos
de extrema derecha que en redes sociales
intentaron minimizar las acciones de los
dos guardias de seguridad este sábado el
presidente ayer bolsonaro prestó
importancia
estructural en su país donde más de la
mitad de la población se identifica como
negra o mestiza